hello let us talk about the Hunger Games
and this is a very interesting sort of
film experience if it's that those are
the words I used because the build-up
for this movie in the marketing for this
movie isn't like something like one of
the comic book movies up there Twilight
or something like that where there's a
lot backing the advertising and
everywhere you go it's you know you see
the title uh this didn't have like a ton
of advertisement it's there I mean you
know everyone's while you look around
you see a poster but it wasn't extreme
and this got a huge following though and
this was like one the hyped anticipated
films simply because of the following it
had and it has this really huge teenager
a teenage and a little younger following
of people that love the books
and they got really except for this
movie and everyone's saying this is
gonna be like one of the big hits I mean
like the one the really really big ones
so that's pretty interesting it's very
interesting for a film to be a hit just
based off of word of mouth you know cuz
it rarely happens and what it does
that's kind of cool it's like how it
should work but okay so with that said
let's actually talk about the film
itself I really liked it I thought this
was I had to admit the reason I probably
liked it as much as I did even though
it's good I think I like to even more
for the fact that it was it's a young
adult book and so therefore it's
marketed mostly to teenagers and stuff
like that
I think that's why I like it as much as
I do if it wasn't I like it you know
it'd be good but I think I like as much
as I do because of that because when you
think of stuff coming out like Twilight
transformers and stuff like that stuff
that's obviously marketed the sort of
teens and younger but is obvious junk
food and junk foods okay every once a
while but we love to feed it to you know
our younger people so anytime something
comes along that it's not only smart but
really treats its audience especially
its younger audience like
know what they're talking about like
they're smart and they have a brain and
they can comprehend tough stuff and they
can be challenged I'm all for it
now with that said it can be very very
extreme and very intense which when I
was watching and I didn't know what to
think of it outside you want Jesus it's
like a teenage book I mean really but
then again I was thinking when I was a
teenager I was watching aliens and all
that other violent stuff I mean this is
nothing new and the movie acts that way
it acts like look we know our audience
we do and you know we're gonna treat
them like they're smart people who can
take this stuff you know what they can
they really can and we're gonna treat
our characters with this dignity and
we're gonna treat a story with this
dignity and we're going to talk
intelligent we're gonna make the people
sound intelligent they are gonna be
intelligent and we're gonna create this
world that's very fascinating and
complex and raises questions to younger
people and stuff so good for this movie
I mean I I really give it a lot of
credit for that
the basic story real fast is that
there's a sort of this future Orwellian
world where you know are sort of like
metropolis where you have you know the
rich and successful you know are high up
and living the glamorous life and the
people down below the less successful or
constantly being take advantage of and
what they do from what I was told this
is only burger got a little confusing is
that in these districts of people that
are not very wealthy and are constantly
in control you know are being controlled
by the richer people they have said I
guess the district's tried to up rise
and they tried to have a rebellion that
didn't work so as punishment there's
this game that the rich people now play
where every every year they take like
one young boy one young girl from every
district and they pull them in this game
where only one person can come out the
alive it's pretty much like you know an
arena like gladiators and stuff like
that just throw them in there watch and
kill each other but just play to a very
you know futuristic technological
you know extreme you know they're like
you know like what we do today I like
American Idol pretty much though they
don't kill people in there but wouldn't
it be more interesting show I digress so
and this girl and this boy get chosen
from this district it's pretty much just
following them particularly the girl and
and just how they survive in the world
that this is and so on so forth so
that's the basic premise this world that
they've created is nothing really that
new we've seen this kind of world before
LA so it's even a term for us or the
Orwellian well you know it's very la
available 1984 obviously Brazil did this
oh I plug in the name the guy has the
mask
everyone always clothes I'm gonna do an
edit here just so I can think of a man V
for Vendetta
that was it great about that um so I
mean we've seen these kind of worlds
before where it's really almost like the
Nazis took over and there's a lot of
control and stuff and the rich are
glamorous and powerful and don't care
about the the poor and needy and blah
blah blah or you know so oh we see this
before but what this film does different
and this is what I like it updates it
and it also sort of mixes the those
traditional stories that sort of a
traditional look like this looks very
much like Brazil and you know with the
very cold buildings a lot of gray and
stuff like that but also updates it with
you know almost sort of a satire of our
technology today and our shows today and
stuff like that the fashions of today I
mean these are all very over-the-top
extreme fashions where everyone's trying
hard so hard to look so glamorous if
they just look hideous and I love that I
love the Bama talk-show talking to these
kids before they go out and fight and
how and the kids are also learning how
to be celebrities I think that's a great
update to this kind of story you know
cuz that also can be very savage and
literally the more sponsors they can get
and the more people they can please the
better chance they have to literally
survive not just in terms of a public
image but literally survive I mean
that's that's wonderful and everything
sort of does look like this American
Idol set up and you know people even
though these people are fighting for
their life
people are talking about you know what
they're wearing and stuff like that is
just that great satire and that's so
current it's so modern and if there's
anyone who can get that you know the
teen audience really can and I think
this stuff does hit them and they do get
it I think it shows with how popular the
books are and how what a big hit those
movies obviously gonna be I mean why
what there's a huge line to get in you
know I have a sold-out show so um so I
really like it because of that I like
these characters are very good and I
guess in a sense are sort of these
archetypes you're used to but there's
much more humanity in these kid doesn't
they big good actors to play them I mean
these could very easily be I mean this
could just be a cardboard cutout you
know the really tough girl and they even
saw her the wimpy boy but it's like you
know the boy is not just a wimp I mean
he actually is very strong but he gets
nervous and he understand heavily so he
wants to survive I mean he's actually
much like the other kids in this film
and the girl is very headstrong you know
but she she doesn't know how to play to
the crowd and so she has to be taught
that you know sort of a different way of
survival because she knows one way to
survival I mean this this is all very
clever stuff a very smart stuff the
adult actors are all great live in this
very you know like I said a very creepy
over-the-top future if it has a future I
just realized I'm not never said the
future could just be an alternate world
but again I digress a fault with the
movie it's I think they're pretty minor
in my opinion but it can give to some
people I mean one is that it is constant
shaky-cam throughout the whole thing
there's very few shots that are just
still or very slowly panning or anything
like that I mean it's all shaky cam but
now the interesting thing about that is
well fakey can for the most prized not
bothered me too much except for a one
instance where I'll get to in a second
so literally when this film starts off
and I saw on an IMAX the whole screen is
shaking I mean like 90% of the time but
I found I was actually sort of getting
into that and I think it's because a lot
of times people are just standing around
and not doing anything really
action-oriented and it did
to create this unease it sort of felt
like you're just there sort of watching
these people I didn't make it much more
uncomfortable which is what this zone is
supposed to be it's supposed to be very
uncomfortable and very intense so I
found myself at you start getting into
the Zen of the shake if that's yeah turn
which I know it isn't but I started
getting into it except for one thing
whenever they do the action sequences
guys you gotta see the action you can't
be okay the purpose of action is to
create suspense that the character will
get out you know or that there's a
conflict or something like that if you
can't see any of that then how can you
get invested you're just gonna be there
confused I mean when someone comes up
you just see this the whole time maybe a
person's face and then back that you
can't get into it you can't but the big
fight scene at the end I had no idea who
was fighting you know what halfway
through I mean I I sort of took a guess
because of how many were left but I mean
I was just like okay well I'm assuming
it's this guy but I don't know I can't
see them so that's that's really
annoying uh but again for the rest of
the shaky-cam and there are still shots
on like they need to show the city it
looks very nice and the you know the
great shots with like the advertisers
and the TV shows and stuff like that all
look great um but yeah if you're not
good at shaky-cam you really can't take
this over you can't take play Witcher
and so on so forth don't see you that
IMAX you're gonna hurl I think you have
a real hard time I can't imagine this
was in 3d oh god there's so many
close-ups in this movie you just be
seeing like freckles this big you know
IMAX 3d I mean it just would not you
know jumping out at you so it's really
good they didn't do this in 3d um so
what else what else and like I said
before the it's very very intense the
violence it's not gory but I mean it's
you pretty much got it's children
killing children essentially I mean some
are teenagers were teenagers but others
are like you know it look like they're
about 11 or 10 or something like that so
I mean it gets very very extreme so keep
that in mind I mean if you're just like
this is a team book it'll be you know
okay maybe a little rough here and there
no it they really treat this seriously
and they give it a lot of weight and
again good for this film it's really
taking a chance I I would have no idea
how to market this film if I was doing
this I mean this is essentially killing
kids the sport yeah how do you market us
to be fine again I'm really impressed
that this is like a series and film
series it's gonna be a film series that
really caught on I'm really impressed by
that I think that's very cool that the
you know as a younger audience out there
not that that there's this smart but
there's this many that are this smart I
think that's awesome
and that there's still film studios that
will take this material and not dumb it
down I saw with my brother who read the
books and he says there's changes you
know there's stuff he didn't like but he
says what's essentially the book so it
really wasn't dumped down it was done it
treats it off its audience I get it's
very adult it is long as well keep that
in mind the bill that reminds me a lot
of Full Metal Jacket it's very much the
first half is just the build-up then the
second half is the actual game love that
love good build-up I love I mean they do
such a great job of make you feel the
pressure at these kids are gonna go
through without even fully telling you
what it is either which I kind of like I
mean so there's still a lot of Secrets
and so forth when you're going in so
this was a very smart very well put
together film I think that people who
wouldn't like it
our pride people who couldn't handle the
intensity because it is very intense
like I said people can't handle the
shaky can there's a lot of that like it
sort of grew on me except for the action
scenes but that's definitely something
to keep in mind that can get very very
annoying and maybe people who are just
sick of the you know the future that
sucks you know because there are so many
of those stories that well a it's never
gonna go away I mean their cautionary
tales this is what our future can be but
if you're sick of that story and you're
sick of the rich people looking really
glamorous and watching the poor people
you know you you might not like this
either I think it's done pretty smart I
like because it adds new things to it
and it updates it and improves it in
certain points but there are people that
can be really sick of and I can totally
understand that because we do SMA of
these stories but for my money
I really liked it I'm glad that teens
are really getting into it
even though I would usually say it's
like too violent you know step by kit
it's not kids kids it's teenagers and
this is when they're craving this stuff
that craving the violence they're
craving all this stuff and it's good if
you're gonna have this stuff have it for
a reason to have it with ideas have it
was something that's gonna challenge you
you know and don't make it glamorous
it's not glamorous you know when the
hero kills our heroes it kills somebody
in this that you know they're not like
you know go here it's like you're just
sad that the person had to do that I
mean cuz they it's just kids killing
kids so it's really well done and I
admit that the reason I like it so much
is because of the audience it's geared
towards and even if this wasn't the
audience I would still like it but I
wouldn't love it as much as I did but
because they are talking to the teenage
demographic as starring teenagers smart
teenagers trained teenagers like they're
smart I really really enjoyed this film
and it's a very it's a very adult film
for younger people I love that so guys
that's my two cents I'll see you later